[Musique]
Émilie Nicolas Michel David Chantal
Hébert bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
On va commencer avec sa maman c'est
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas parlé de lui
on en parle depuis quelques jours ça
m'amad on en avait déjà parlé je pense
Chantal je vous en parliez il y a
quelques mois sauf erreur qui une des
cibles de pierre poirieres au Québec
dans la région de Québec spécifiquement
ça m'a mal très populaire dans la région
de Québec pourrait se présenter dans
Louis Hébert par exemple on écoute ça
répond aussi
tout le monde m'appelle
je retourne toutes les appels mais il y
a pas de décision
rien rien
pour le moment absolument rien rien rien
je commence avec vous il avait pris sa
carte du parti parce qu'il appuyait Jean
Charest à l'époque donc il y a quasiment
un pied dans la porte là
vous allez peut-être un peu vite en
affaire à l'époque les gens qui m'en
avaient parlé il m'avait parlé des rives
Gérard on n'est pas exactement dans la
même ligue moi je vais en parler après
mais commençons par sa maman on s'entend
sa maman de c'est une nouveauté sur la
planète poids lièvre ce qu'on comprend
c'est que on cherche à recruter au
Québec et que c'est pas facile et j'ai
l'impression que avant c'est pas parce
qu'on a pris une carte de membre pour
Jean-Charles qu'on veut se présenter
pour Pierre paulièvre nécessairement
j'ai comme l'impression qu'à peu près
tout le monde va attendre de voir si
dans le dernier sondage à Bacchus celui
de cette semaine le Parti conservateur
au Québec est à 15% 15% même dans la
région de Québec dans une
circonscription qui est libérale dans le
moment c'est pas si prometteur que ça
Michel David
on sent quand même des chantal a raison
de me ramener à là il faut que je met
des fois je m'emballe quand j'ai déjà
fait des reportages avec des candidats
qui ont jamais été chef de partie
Lord Nouveau-Brunswick mais ça fait 1000
ans mais Michel David on sent qu'il a le
goût quand même on le sent ah oui ça a
beaucoup plus l'air d'un oui d'un nom là
ce qu'on entend de la bouche de Monsieur
Hamad quand tu dis j'ai été le
silencieux depuis trop longtemps et là
il nous expliquent presque un programme
électoral quand il nous dit écoutez on
va bâtir un troisième pont on va
privatiser la traverse Québec Lévy
ça a l'air de quelqu'un qui a vraiment
envie de revenir et quand il était battu
à l'époque
ou quand il est parti en fait partie
non non il a été obligé de partir parce
qu'il y avait une controverse sur le
financement à l'époque mais c'est pas
parce qu'il y avait été désavoué par ces
électeurs moi je pense que j'étais là
Québec pendant longtemps pendant que
monsieur Hama était député il était très
apprécié
je sais pas ce qui serait arrivé si
c'était représenté il serait peut-être
battu parce que la marque libérale
disons était passablement amoché mais
s'il se présentait évidemment des
conservateurs
ça va plus ou moins bien dans la région
de Québec mais il reste que je pense que
le goût et qui aurait des chances
Émilie Nicolas il a dit à Mario Dumont
quand Michel parle de programme ce qu'il
y en a dit plus il y a fait une plus
longue entre vue à Mario Dumont midi ou
ce matin puis il a été parlé de la peine
de l'Est qu'on pouvait plus acheter que
c'est à cause de Trudeau il avait un peu
il avait comme adopté le mot à la mode
le narratif de Pierre pollièvre un peu
mais d'abord sa maman n'est plus élue
depuis 2017 donc si vous voulez pas
faire d'entrevue on ferait pas première
des choses donc le simple fait qu'il
soit là c'est ce qu'on appelle tester
des ballons donc qui est là avec son
sourire de sphinx l'homme en train de de
lancer des idées à gauche à droite et à
faire son sondage c'est-à-dire où on
voit bien qu'il y a quelqu'un qui n'est
pas intéressé du tout et puis qui a un
nom ferme ne se lance pas dans ce jeu-là
à faire ce type à faire ce type
d'entrevue-là donc c'est déjà un signal
après qu'on teste des ballons comme ça
quand on lance des idées comme ça je
pense que on cherche à avoir c'est quoi
la réaction lorsqu'on lance on eau comme
ça effectivement ça peut être des
questions sondages mais ça peut être
aussi de voir comment est-ce que le
public réagit à cette idée là est-ce
qu'un appétit pour ça ou pas puis en
fonction de ça on prend une décision
donc c'est pas parce qu'il fait ça que
ça veut dire que tout est déjà ficelé
mais ça veut dire toutefois qu'on essaie
de tester puis d'avoir les réactions de
que ça suscite de retourner comme ça
dans l'espace public quand ces deux
trois idées à gauche à droite de façon
plus générale Chantal
[Musique]
pourquoi il peut garantir ça parce que
même dans un très très bon scénario
personne chez les conservateurs Satan à
élire beaucoup plus de conservateurs que
ce que Steven Harper avait réussi à
élire une dizaine et rappelez-vous ils
étaient presque tous par défaut dans le
conseil des ministres alors
non c'est pas simple se faire lire au
Québec mais oui se faire aider au Québec
c'est une garantie de limousine parce
qu'on ne sait pas quand est-ce que ce
sera après le budget 20 24 une campagne
ça peut être réaliste mais Michel David
Émilie Nicolas poilliev a besoin
effectivement de plat il monte un peu
mais laisse quand même servi chez la
prédire a besoin de montrer que il est
il est tout près d'un poste de Premier
ministre donc il peut attirer des non
crédibles au Québec notamment Michel
ouais ben le dernier sondage à Bacchus
mais quand même assez encourageant pour
pour Monsieur Poirier lui-même mais pour
les conservateurs en général et comme
dit Chantal
une victoire un siège au Québec c'est
presque
garanti d'accéder au Conseil des
ministres et je pense que Monsieur Amad
a pas grand chose à perdre en se
présentant alors je serai pas surpris
qu'il se présente pas mais je serais
tellement pas surpris qu'il y aille
ouais Émilie
en terminant je pense qu'on a parlé de
on a parlé de tout sauf du pont en fait
au sens où Pierre polieve c'est pas bah
c'est pas Jean charrette qui avait amené
sa maman dans politique c'est pas la
même idéologie et ça se peut que il y a
des principes et que sur le fond il y a
des choses que puis après disent qu'il
le fasse hésiter c'est pas c'est ça
plutôt que de seulement calculer d'être
ministre ou pas et je pense que si il y
a des hésitations c'est des
conversations c'est aussi parce que la
proche de pierre pollière au Québec est
pas peut-être claire encore pour tout le
monde mais je pense que c'est important
de nommer qu'il y a encore peut-être la
place pour les principes paysidés en
politique mais comme je disais mais
quand je disais la peine de l'aile je
faisais référence au fond dans la mesure
où il y avait l'impression j'avais
l'impression qu'il y avait comme adopter
un certain discours parliez du sondage à
Bacchus les gens se demandent on peut
vous le montrer rapidement avant de
passer à l'autre sujet les conservateurs
qui sont en montée les libéraux en
décembre mais 33 30 18 7 ça c'est
partout au Canada puis on avait les en
fait le chiffre que de faire plaisir à
poilief c'est qui ferait le meilleur
premier ministre je sais pas si on l'a
mais monsieur poilievre était devant on
était devant Monsieur Trudeau ok
changement de sujet tu l'as mais tu me
montres le montre-le j'en ai parlé on va
le montrer c'est pas là
24 28 monsieur Poirier là donc parmi les
dirigeants de parties merci on aura le
temps d'en reparler les le fédéral qui
ne donne pas de visa pour les études
étrangers des étudiants qui proviennent
d'Afrique essentiellement les trois
quarts des candidatures de l'Afrique
sont rejetées on en a parlé plutôt à
l'émission la ministre du Québec a dit
ceci
le fédéral reconnaît qu'il y a un
problème bon c'est déjà un pas mais il
faut faire des actions faut changer la
donne de manière beaucoup plus rapide
que ça a été le cas jusqu'à maintenant
il y a eu une légère amélioration mais
on est encore très loin de la note de
passage du côté fédéral vraiment il faut
que la change la donne change d'une
manière beaucoup plus significative et
rapide parce que ça a un impact très
important sur nos établissements
d'enseignement sur nos régions également
des étudiants choisis donc par les
universités du Québec qui ont le permis
du Québec qui se bute à un nom de tawa
et l'Afrique c'est du proportionné c'est
comme je vous disais 72% des demandes
sont refusées Milly Nicolas réaction
une énorme idée mais je pense que c'est
important de comprendre que c'est pas
tout le monde qui est pauvre en Afrique
parce qu'on dirait que c'est un peu
comme ça que certains fonctionnaires
réagissent quand on voit la quantité de
questions auxquelles les gens doivent
répondre pour garantir qu'ils ont les
moyens de venir ici comme étudiant
étranger qui vont pas qui sont pas des
risques de de fuite ou que donc ou même
les gens qui sont ici pour avoir des
visas des permis de visite pour leur
famille parfois c'est c'est incroyable
en fait je pense que il semble avoir une
dose de préjugés là-dedans contre
l'Afrique en général et s'influent
s'implique de plus les francophones
parce que les francophones ont fait la
grande majorité de francophones dans le
monde sont sur le continent africain
c'est pire pour les Africains
francophones que sur les pour les
Africains anglophones qu'on a vu sur le
tableau mais ça reste une question de
préjugés que les gens pensent qu'elles
sont bien de la Guinée ou de la Côte
d'Ivoire ou du Sénégal on n'a pas les
moyens de venir au Canada ou qu'on est
dangereux de pouvoir partir sur nous
invite à partir Canada je pense que
franchement il y a une éducation qui
semble vraiment nécessaire à faire au
niveau de la fonction publique fédérale
là-dessus et ça presse Michel
on avait discuté avec la présidente de
l'Institut du Québec c'est totalement
incongru par rapport aux objectifs qu'on
a tant à Ottawa et Québec on dépense des
millions on pourrait y faire en sorte
que ces étudiants là non seulement
viennent ici mais reste après et là
l'objection qu'on a c'est que on veut
pas qu'il reste alors il y a quelque
chose il y a des gens qui se parlent pas
là mais ce qui me trouble encore plus
c'est que pourquoi les étudiants
africains sont plus discriminés en
proportion au Québec quand l'Ontario
c'est les mêmes paperasses j'imagine
qu'on demande aux étudiants africains
qui s'en est à Toronto ou qui viennent
étudier à Montréal alors pourquoi cette
proportion là qui est assez flagrante
d'ailleurs c'est très troublant c'est
comme si on était plus exigeant quand
des gens veulent aller au Québec s'ils
veulent aller s'installer en Ontario et
je rappelle c'est des gens qui ont été
donc les demandes ont été faites d'abord
aux universités approuvées par Québec et
le troisième étape c'est un terme à
Chantal
on a vraiment l'impression effectivement
que le gouvernement fédéral le ministère
fédéral de l'immigration fonctionne à
contresens du gouvernement du Québec
pour des raisons qui sont qui sont
inexplicables en termes administratif ou
habituel donc il y a clairement un
problème et ce qui est frappant c'est
que effectivement la ministre raison si
ça se passait ailleurs si en Ontario ont
refusait tous les étudiants africains
que l'Ontario demande on dirait pas on
pense qu'un problème et on va travailler
là-dessus on s'activerait à toute
vitesse parce qu'il reste scandale et là
parce qu'il est question du Québec on
sait pas trop écoutez il y a une
certaine époque quand il y avait un taux
de chômage élevé au Canada effectivement
c'était la politique du ministère
fédéral de l'immigration d'accepter des
candidats dont on était raisonnablement
certains qu'ils allaient retourner chez
eux
mais là c'est comme si on n'avait pas
fait la mise à jour dans le cerveau
collectif du ministère fédéral de
l'immigration c'est-à-dire non seulement
on y veut mais on veut les garder
incohérence donc je passe aux excuses
fournira Emily fastui après je passe aux
excuses de Bernard drinville hier les
excuses avaient été faites sur Twitter
là les excuses ont été faits en vrai si
je peux dire on écoute
je peux comprendre que certaines d'entre
elles aient pu être blessé par ses
propos là et donc oui je m'excuse auprès
d'elle si ça a été le cas parce que tel
n'était pas mon intention mon intention
c'était juste de dire écoutez les
métiers sont tellement différents les
uns des autres ça devient difficile de
comparer c'est ça que je voulais dire
mais c'était surtout pas l'idée de dire
que les enseignants pourraient moins
importantes que les députés
moi j'aime ça quelqu'un qui est assez
humble pour reconnaître un moment donné
bon peut-être mes propos ont pas été dit
exactement comme j'aurais dû les dire
moi je pense les Québécois après ça
d'avoir de l'humidité
bon suite et fin Michel David vous ne
compariez pas dans votre question le
salaire des députés que le salaire des
enseignants vous compariez les
enseignants du Québec avec la moyenne
canadienne puis les députés du Québec
avec la moyenne canadienne
je pense est assez intelligent pour
comprendre la différence et il a été je
pense pris de court d'une part par la
question et
il voulait pas comme il avait fait en
2015 dire écoutez cette augmentation là
des salades des députés ça a pas de bon
sens par rapport aux enseignants et aux
infirmiers à ce qu'ils disaient quand le
gouvernement Charret avait Couillard
plutôt avait proposé une hausse du
salaire des députés mais ce que ce que
j'ai pas aimé disons c'est que les
excuses sont quand même venues un peu à
retardement hier et il s'excusait pas il
disait j'ai pas voulu insinuer que alors
tout le monde avait vu l'entrevue sur
vidéo tout le monde avait tiré déjà sa
conclusion alors il y aurait peut-être
dû s'excuser hier plutôt que d'attendre
encore un autre 24 heures ce qui donne à
penser que ce sont des excuses qui lui
ont été presque imposées par monsieur
Legault et de toute façon je convaincu
que monsieur Legault les excuses il
trouve peut-être ça sympathique mais il
y aurait mieux qu'il y a pas assez
excuser
Chantal
ouais l'entendre parce que la lire la
déclaration Stan shoes mais l'entendre
c'était se dire et c'est ce qui est un
peu étonnant en s'entendant Bernard
drinville aurait dû se dire je dois
m'excuser parce que n'importe qui qui
entend ça et pas besoin d'être
enseignants se dit c'est qui ce
personnage là et en plus c'est le
Ministre l'éducation donc de prendre
deux jours je suis d'accord avec Michel
ça fait
excuse obligé la deuxième journée parce
que la première journée c'était trop du
bout des lèvres Émilie
de toute façon c'était même pas
nécessairement son dossier à défendre
tant que ça ou sans sous-communiste de
l'éducation sa job c'est de défendre les
augmentations du budget donc en
éducation donc le tout était étrange à
tellement de niveau de niveau possible
c'était pas la croix sur laquelle il
devait il devait s'immoler du tout et
pourtant il le choisit de le faire
peut-être un brûle pour point parce que
Michel Le déconcentré et puis ça a pris
48 heures après pour pour
s'excuser c'est c'est dommage et puis
surtout je pense que la citation de 2015
où il dit exactement le contraire je
pense que c'est ça aussi que qui a fait
mal de voir encore une fois que à quel
point les politiciens peuvent changer
d'idées comme ça au fil des années ce
qui m'amène selon Émilie faster ancienne
député la CAQ d'en Charlevoix côte de
Beaupré à l'idée du marketing elle
dénonce ce que certains députés quand
ils partent dénonce elle dit il y a trop
de marketing on va écouter
madame Fosseux elle a publié un texte
mais aussi la voici en vrai elle aussi
que c'est mieux de montrer une image
unie avec une équipe unie mais de là à
le faire sur tous les enjeux tout le
temps systématiquement ça c'est une
autre chose sur des choses sensibles
comme voter contre rapport des
commissaire haltique oui moi j'ai eu un
immense malaise j'apprécie beaucoup
pierre fait du Gabin cependant sur la
dessus on n'était pas d'accord
alors qu'en pensez-vous à Émilie je
commence avec vous tour de table
mais c'est sûr que à chaque fois qu'il y
a des députés qui font un mandat il y en
a qui vont avoir une désillusion la
manière dont ça fonctionne à l'Assemblée
nationale qui sont pas du tout à l'aise
avec la ligne de partie c'est pas
nouveau ce qui se passe en ce moment
ceci dit je pense que dans le contexte
de la CAF on a vu en fin de semaine
dernière avec un congrès plusieurs ont
qualifié de fan club vraiment où il y a
quelque chose dans la culture de la
discipline de la duulation peut-être
même du Premier ministre de la disons de
la loi lyauté qui est peut-être encore
plus forte à la CAQ d'ailleurs vu que
c'est un parti qui a été créé par par le
Premier ministre donc il y a quelque
chose qui est très classique donc dans
ce qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment-là quand il y a des députés qui
ont du recul et qui voit à quel point le
système à l'Assemblée nationale peut
être étouffant pour pour les personnes
derrière moi mais en même temps il y a
aussi quelque chose à la carte qui
pourrait peut-être peut-être intéressant
de regarder est-ce que c'est plus fort
là qu'ailleurs mais Michel est Chantal
est-ce que ça ne fait pas partie de de
certain nombre des règles du jeu quand
même si les députés sortent à gauche à
nous on va faire nos choux gras avec ça
mais Michel comment vas-tu oui mais
c'est clair que pour nous c'est du
bonbon un député qui sort du rang
maintenant j'ai l'impression que à la
CAQ un problème particulier c'est à dire
que
on comprend que la ligne de partie la
solidarité ministérielle c'est quand
même assez important imaginer il y a pas
il y a pas juste le budget ou d'émotions
de l'arme là imaginé si par exemple la
troisième lien le dès le départ il y
avait le tiers des députés qui avaient
commencé à dire c'est pas justifié ça a
pas de bon sens ça s'arrêter assez
compliqué à gérer mais quand on est au
pouvoir il est clair qu'on a pas la même
liberté de parole que quand on est dans
l'opposition mais normalement on peut se
comment dire se compenser en disant ce
qu'on pense à l'intérieur du caucus à
l'extérieur on fait froid quand même
mais au cocus on peut dire ce qu'on
pense à ce que Madame Foster a l'air de
nous dire c'est que même à l'intérieur
du caucus kakiste les députés ont pas
cette cette liberté là que il se sentent
cont les conseillers du Premier ministre
etc alors là il y a une soupape qui
manque j'ai l'impression à la CAQ parce
que si on peut pas parler à l'extérieur
on devrait avoir au moins la chance de
le faire à l'intérieur quelque part dans
la cuisine Chantal je vous écoute et
puis je l’impression de nous entendre
parler du gouvernement Steven Harper et
c'est peut-être en partie le fait des
parties plus nouveaux c'est à dire
Harper reconstituer la carte un nouveau
parti c'est à dire qu'on amène beaucoup
de gens qui ont pas d'expérience en
politique et on se dit on va les
contrôler le problème et je pense que
Michel a dû le voir comme moins au fil
des années c'est que d'un gouvernement à
l'autre sans égard à la personnalité du
gouvernement se contrôle exercer par des
non élus du personnel politique a
augmenté au point où on transforme un
peu les députés en peine de l'aile sont
tous blancs on revient à la peine de la
chantas extraordinaires Chantal Michel
Émilie merci beaucoup à très bientôt au
revoir au revoir au revoir